[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you missy so great to be here
today
at the banana banana moore's banana
ramamore's banana morris morse
this is great this is amazing mitzi i
got into
this business show business 25 years ago
to become a movie star now
i'm standing in front of a banner with a
banana
telling jokes into a computer
in my house what happened i have to set
up
this whole thing in my garage that's all
i have
i you know why i'm in my garage because
my wife and kids
have taken over my house with the
lockdown they're out there right now in
the house they're zooming they're
booming they're gooming everything i
have
they took over i i'll tell you
i'll tell you this is the other thing my
agents my managers
said listen there's no touring this year
this is last year once the pandemic
started there's no touring under the
pandemic
but it's a good time for you to build up
your social media you got to start
posting some videos
so i did i started posting videos and i
don't know why but every time i post a
video
i lose 120 followers what is that
why are they leaving where are they
going just
give the video a thumbs down but don't
leave where are you
going and the comments
on social media forget it people drive
me nuts
oh listen first of all
last year i decided to lose
10 pounds by running and eating right
that's what i decided
and then i thought you know what i'm
gonna do i'm going
to inspire my fans to also
exercise lose weight let's do it
together
so i said i'm going to start posting
pictures of my weight loss
as i go i when i stood on my little
electric scale
i stood there i took pictures every day
i would post pictures
of my weight loss as i went along
started reading the comments
right away comment number one dude your
toes are ugly
what the i'm trying to inspire you to
lose weight
why are you worried about my toes
every comment was about my ugly toes i
stopped running
yeah what are you gonna do
i can't wait to get back on the road
thank you for having me
at the banana moors comedy club stay
safe and namaste
laugh at your screen
thanks for coming to bananamores